[Musique]
bb alex est entrée dans la famille de
jon raymond à la mi janvier
ce bébé quand intervilles était pas
capable d'avoir le contact peau à peau
avec nous ils se poussent est carrément
c'est une de ces femmes sur qui la dpj
peut compter pour accueillir et prendre
soin de baby pendant quelques mois
ce soin des enfants pour investit alors
avec des rapports qu'on doit stimuler
par le jeu par le toucher par les
caresses parce qu'ils ont peu connus
finalement avec le petit alex on est à
74 bébé sur une période de 21 ans j'ai
tout le temps eu de l'intérêt pour les
petits bébés j'en aurais eu moi même
plus que juste 2 c'est une véritable
histoire de famille la mère de mon
mérite et familles d'accueil pour cent
cinquante enfants et plus des enfants
handicapés
alors c'est comme une passion qu'on
avait on voulait faire ça très jeune
dans notre vie la burqa n'est plus
habité ma fille eric à qui mon bras
droit
maman numéro deux avec les bébés
des fonds que ça demande un don de soi
d'être amis d'accueil sans lendemain
disponibilité aussi d'être familles
d'accueil sont puis avec des bébés
d'autant plus et si ce genre de personne
qui manque cruellement à la dpj
le nombre de familles d'accueil à
montréal a chuté de 9 cents en 2011 à
trois cents seulement
nous avons des familles d'accueil qui
peuvent accueillir des plus grands du
helmand mais la problématique est
principalement pour recevoir des enfants
de 0 5 ans
la pub que j'ai c'est sûr aussi que des
familles d'accueil qui selon tension
famille d'accueil qui sont
vieillissantes qui est moralement rythme
et il faut faut de la relève bhl c'est
ce qui nous manque actuellement le sait
ces dramatiques en termes de manque de
classe et appris à aimer le vin qui
s'avance pas bien maintenant depuis le
1er mars aig a commencé à faire signer
complet dans son lit parce qu'elles
constituent un début qui est arrivé dans
mes jeux dans le monde entre le besoin
d'éloigner un enfant de parents crise et
le temps de déterminer ce qui sera mieux
pour lui à plus long terme ces familles
d'accueil joue un rôle crucial
alary vraiment faire des miracles avec
ses enfants le parce que avec
l'intensité qu'elle donne puis avec le
fait qu'elle aime beaucoup les 20
familles encadrés par les services
sociaux il faut aussi composer avec les
parents naturels
or soit des appels de ses parents laudun
fois sont pas tout en gratifiant vers
nous parce qu'ils nous prennent comme
une menace
son qui fait oublier la difficulté de se
séparer d'un petit pensionnaire le
moment venu
même si ça fait mal je capable de
reprendre sur moi en disant ben il y en
aura un autre qui vont harvey pekar
aussi besoin ici anne louise despatie
radio canada montréal